so Cuba most rapidly is like terms
training but it's not possible I start
with a description I have an assigned
destination which means I got to do
whatever it takes to get there okay you
got that so every deviation from the
assigned destination is a failure in my
G wuzzle be able to the various micro
adaptations and adjustments make every
technique and exactly the same way
regardless of the beginning the
regardless of the rep I don't need to
have that good again who makes my
technique work the only energies that I
am allowed to use is koku and I clean I
don't use my muscle in this training
okay my strategy is always the jiu-jitsu
strategy ideal okay so yes I have a
destination but if I don't he'll I'm not
even in the ballpark if I use another
engine another energy engine other than
projection in an adhesion coke you and I
key I'm not doing the heart you got that
so I have a destination can't just go
make it and I didn't do jujitsu and I
didn't use coke you like you got it okay
so I'm doing my same techniques I don't
okay
[Music]
engage
all those modifications
he does it every time he goes out it
hurts right but to you it looks like
he's the best you camber okay it's not
to you I I don't have the form I just do
whatever it's just habit and if I
haven't learned to reconcile fear it's
just habitual fear you're leaving
details now how's the habit of them
how's the foot code there's a tiny thing
all that is part of it I don't have to
go
you see I'm not racing her same thing
where do you want to go only where I'm
telling her he's not following me she's
not running around dis movements in her
centre that movements in her centre
she's not taking a camera
she's receiving the technique
because of that I don't have to race I
just keep these pressures going you see
I get any point make me stop I can't
stop can't stop I can't stop can you get
up you see you don't bother that high
okay I don't need your desktop
I wanted her senator Bach floor
[Music]
shame looks hurt Kevin looks like
Ariel's looks like running okay it's
Bobby Kevin are you keep falling if
you're paying attention to the pressure
on the elbow so let's say she is she
wants to get up boom and she wants to
fall outward because I take her elbow
she wanted to kick out
[Music]
okay
so we're not doing the technique so you
want you want him I don't know make you
see how does that connection see look he
goes that way that's so easy with okay
[Music]
the two nouns are redundant right watch
watch it Santa's here just check here
they're not pretended I take one away
that won't work is there they're working
levers on the arm I'm working
this section bodies here save me a spot
feel steady here around infinite spot
input in this body oh let it down
so each hand should feel like nothing
where I feel the most pressure is here
it's the energies bouncing back and
forth off the ground this other stuffs
very light very much move on to pressure
with me
[Music]
that's how I'm old one back to New York
correction like this commending me to
come closer to come in it's not coming
you have to go backwards hey doctor
wants to go forward she goes forward and
come into you did you not control a move
on okay take that you're using more than
2 pounds of pressure it's not gonna work
you could use that to motivate yourself
to get better okay
this do you also if you pay attention to
every time you deviate from the final
destination or every time you have
entually just do a fear response where
and you lose the details of the form if
you pay attention either at that moment
but more often just preceding that
moment your mind also deviated you'll
move deviated your thoughts came in and
of course your breathing pattern
deviated okay so you cannot have every
you can look the same until those
internal systems stop deviating okay so
as we go he does he does I'm gonna talk
my mind as we go okay so you can see
there's a lot of fluctuation in what's
happening okay so we go whoa he didn't
get a good grip like I felt that okay my
mind won't do that don't worry about me
dude the head slippery I can tell it's
slippery oh he's already
see what interview talk about it okay
but it's very hard she's got an injury
he's got a ghost injury and he want my
gold okay all this tension is here you
see there was no reason why he went like
that
like the ghost injury tensed up and come
over here and now he has to try to relax
okay so even in his caring lots of
variation but my mind will sense all
those things but not respond to them the
thought will come and I will release the
thought okay now doing the same thing
every time my mind hits his heart I
release it physiologically in my body
[Music]
shake my breath let's eat my paws this
all this body that's a wandering mind
forget it
the pauses that's my mind stopping
veteran then catching up one smooth
motion
no matter who they are or what they do
reach back
did you feel the two pulses when you
came back
there was one she witnessed you one
there's another one
did you feel them now okay so when I
have to poke you it's gonna protect you
you get it so right now slow you
twisting okay so you she still can't
come forward okay pay attention to the
poultry you're trying to go into the
wall okay come on go again
so I know I'm again she wants to pull
out she wants to fall out she doesn't
get to fall out I have control of her
center wolf you see too much foot stand
up stand up stand up stand up stand up
till I go okay try to get with
through IP okay I'm not dropping here so
Ludo hello everyone you see hey check it
that way take take it up towards me it's
not robbing it's just this adhesion then
but when I get here yeah
send it same thing same thing just like
sort work okay zero pressure he wants to
go forward I just follow him forward
we're not bidding see he wants to go
back he's going to you yeah he
wants to go out
no he wants to come in no okay come on
so you're going here yeah no cheer okay
a bomb pop the elbow I go below you can
do above I'm here like this if he
bends his arm
it doesn't mom I still have that okay so
here here from that here
boom from that trap so it looks like I'm
not loading him but I am good move move
you see it's no different than the sword
the sword is stuck to the sword okay
he can only pull away but I just stand
with okay try to describe a Jian the try
okay it's you're still external yes I
have contact yes I have contact
yes I have a drawn vector but the energy
that I'm generating in the Kazushi is
also has to be calculated okay so and
we're just standing here that's going to
be a totally different amount of
pressure each hand is doing and each
vector in order to stay stuck as he's
starting to move that's a different
pressure value on the top and a
different vector on each hand in order
to stay stuck and same thing as he falls
so I can I go it's a value 10 vector Y
but then when he falls
you see you lost it you see that it's a
constant changing what am i changing I'm
changing this cross so if I look here if
he tries what if you just work on a
two-dimensional flat props
okay if he pushes into me you'll feel
the IP on this hand
do you feel that and then the kokyu on
this hand okay so this line this way is
more about hope you have but there's
always a little
okay if he pulls if he pulls out he
feels to poke to you on the front hand
and there's a I see on the back hand
okay you got it if he goes far over he's
going to feel I'll hook you on this hand
I he on this hand you see eyes make them
for them it becomes back it reverses do
you see so each direction has that you
don't like you cook you delineation on
each hand but then is dominated by
whatever that is so this point of the
process might be call to you I key I key
cook you you got it and then it can
rotate that it's not a two-dimensional
world so I think it's jacked up I'm just
rotating inside that cross to fit my
knee and that's where you guys are
loosing the transition so as I come
around here this part you're worried to
do you see that because you don't have
them in him trapped in the cross you're
like cuz there's nothing there a regular
it's like it's on and then it's off
there's nothing there but here all this
is a lot all this is a lot it's nothing
he's trapped in that cross okay
so don't race it if you're shooting for
that car okay let's go do it today but
ideally the noggin is doing g1 so as
described say in this case is
reconciling the energies with the form
prescription through the modes of
operation I think called you in the
strategy of jujitsu from a young
perspective I have to get do it from a
union perspective so I do my
prescription if I can't make it the same
every single time he can't make his
technique the same every single time
okay so I don't have a prescribed Kimmy
that makes enough sense okay so if you
can do the form I get do you awesome he
gets to you as though okay if you can't
do the form if I could do choose one or
two things one I can let him do the form
by getting myself via adapting to their
F up so their body finds the form now
I'm really training as you can or two I
can just keep adapting to
a thought-form it was their job to get
to the final destination we never got
there to get it but I keep reconciling
yin and Yan as we go okay so I will feel
wait I have my initial displacement I
have to do that bird the contract he
reconciled i reconcile same thing he's
pushing me I'm here on this ground
Decker okay
so s as he goes I can do coke cuties you
see but my job is the yen job so I don't
you poke you back on here I receive the
technique by taking his energy taking it
off taking it off
any same way my mind is not my mind is
outside
my mind is in gorge septons just like
hisses
maybe
here
you